with each new release from dynasty
warriors developer omega force the word
warriors gets further away from the word
dynasty the musso action genre it
created where you play as an ultra
powerful soldier against an army of
hundreds is borrowing more and more from
the franchises it licenses story and
characters from hyrule warriors age of
calamity looked and even sometimes felt
like breath of the wild persona 5
strikers which lacks warriors in the
title but is still a musso game plays
like an extension of persona 5 but with
a different combat style this trend
among omega forces games is a positive
one as you can only press the y button
so many times before you want to do
something different fire emblem warriors
3 hopes offers perhaps the most
opportunity to entertain yourself
outside of comboing through thousands of
enemies that the studio has released yet
thanks to its fire emblem three houses
inspired content between missions the
result is a better paced more
interesting experience than previous
omega force games but one that is still
very much a musso game
[Music]
where the original fire emblem warriors
presented an ultimately unfulfilled
opportunity to meet and play with the
larger history of fire emblem characters
three hopes reigns in the focus and is
essentially a alternate telling of three
houses that is an action game instead of
a tactics rpg you won't run into
characters like roy or marth but you do
have the choice to join edelgard's black
eagles prince dimitri's blue lions or
the correct choice claude's golden deers
if you've played three houses seeing
these characters and agonizing over the
choice again is nice but this time
you're playing as a new character named
chez whose appearance throws the
timeline out of sync and forces former
three house's protagonist bilif into the
antagonist role the departure gives an
illuminating new look at the story
allowing you to interact with familiar
characters under new circumstances this
change also made me admire bileth in a
new way as she destroyed me the first
time i met her and proved to be a worthy
challenge on nearly every subsequent
rematch before and after combat
encounters is where three hopes is
closest to three houses and doesn't feel
like a typical musso game between
pressing y arguably too much you visit
base camp where you can upgrade
facilities train speak with your
soldiers make a meal or even take care
of horses i enjoyed the reprieve from
the repetitive combat and though i
didn't want to hear from every character
between battles and often elected not to
the opportunity to get to know the cast
of characters improve all the
interpersonal relationships and make
them stronger during combat really made
me eager to return to base camp there is
nothing we cannot achieve
i even enjoyed the strangeness of going
on the occasional date between
slaughtering opposing troops base camp
doesn't change visually as a result of
upgrades which is disappointing but
leveling up and improving the facilities
is rewarding for the bonuses they
provide like faster training or stores
being able to carry more supplies combat
is disappointingly familiar to past
musso games where you fight literally
hundreds of the same enemies over and
over with repeated combos the muso
combat formula is one that is always
impressive in the early hours but wears
out it's welcome as every fight starts
to feel the same the numerous tutorials
that still pop up regularly even five
hours into the game don't help matters
but little spikes of fun do appear when
you pull off an especially destructive
special attack against a huge number of
enemies where age of calamity and
strikers played with core mechanics by
adding breath of the wild's flurry
attacks and runes and persona 5's
stealth to mix up the repetitive action
respectively three hopes is a small
shuffle backwards you press the y button
repeatedly to build up combos and
unleash ultimate attacks on the soldier
who just happens to be pulsating green
on the overhead map combos and limited
use special abilities mix up the
fighting and new in-battle fast travel
options help speed up the overall pace
of the action but it all amounts to
ignoring most of the enemies to focus on
a few generals and ping-ponging between
them your choice of class dictates who
you are strong against and i changed
shez's often as you are encouraged to
level each class up individually classes
like cavalier and pegasus knight puts
you on horseback while swordmaster makes
you run faster every class for every
character changes how they look which is
great but it doesn't change how they
play in a meaningful way which is
disappointing the fire emblem inspired
strategy layer has been greatly approved
since the first fire emblem warriors
game and engaging with it is a lot more
fulfilling
you can get as granular as you want
commanding your individual soldiers to
attack and defend specific zones and
enemies but i found great joy in sending
my whole army on singular missions to
take out the bases i was ignoring or
telling them to all follow me as i
sprinted toward a particularly powerful
foe the team is truly helpful and your
relationship with all of them grows
alongside their power levels as you
interact with them between missions
chatting everyone up and learning about
them makes it exciting to see them
succeed on the battlefield i did run
into a handful of occasions where
suddenly the battle was lost and i
wasn't sure what happened an enemy
general was suddenly in an area they
weren't supposed to be or one of my
bases fell when i didn't even know it
was in trouble your attention is
sometimes too divided and the single
objective description on the side of the
screen just isn't enough to keep you in
the loop the worst case and most
frustrating scenario which thankfully
only happened a few times is when i lost
a battle and the checkpoint dropped me
into an impossible scenario where there
were only a few moments before losing
those instances force a mission to be
restarted entirely which i always hated
doing missions are selected by looking
at a region on a map and making your way
from base camp to a final destination
territory by territory you can elect to
take over every section of the region or
you can be lined to your final goal to
speed things up there is something
joyful about slowly overtaking the map
with each battle and watching your color
overtake the world but when i don't want
to participate in every battle i
appreciate that i can be a completionist
to gain a few extra levels of materials
or only participate in the battles i
need to i also like the bonuses that
appear after taking over a small section
once a section is complete you earn
little stories that accompany collecting
resources from one locations getting to
know your co-workers is the highlight
but the larger narrative falls flat and
the decisions you make to direct the
story don't make a radical impact the
production values are impressive with
fully voiced and well-animated cut
scenes showing leaders making difficult
decisions about where and how to direct
troops but i struggled to get invested
and was often confused with the
political machinations of the various
interests the competing goals of your
opponents are never made clear and the
elaborate plans being constructed always
amount to
surprise attacking hundreds of enemies
to take out various forgettable generals
going on a date with claude and talking
about how much we like feasts is way
more interesting than watching him hold
his hand to his chin and commiserate
about why the oppressive church is bad
and we should probably fight them what i
want is the upper hand against the
empire not these people's lives the
musso games have been on an upward
trajectory ever since omega 4 stepped
outside of its dynasty comfort zone this
along with the recent releases has shown
a stronger willingness to embrace the
unique mechanics of the franchises it is
borrowing from and three hopes is one of
the strongest examples yet the
repetitive and sometimes frustrating
combat however is what makes up the
majority of the experience even with
improvements the base idea behind the
combat still loses its luster quickly if
you squint though you arrive at
something closer to a fire emblem three
houses extension as opposed to a
licensed spin-off hoping to cash in on
recognizable characters and locations
which is a good place to be
[Music]
you